Oh laughs welcome to the iron Lords
podcast episode number 43 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got a very special guest PSX
impressions Game Awards impressions and
the release of the curse of Osiris DLC
to discuss so we're gonna get right into
it I want to introduce Lord whose energy
and passion
I respect out here in these gaming
streets although this Lords content is
predominately PlayStation centric he is
never afraid to keep it real with the
Sony base as well as engage and healthy
debate with those who respect gaming
mmm-hmm introducing the host of the
gamers who play games podcasts and
online arcade the Lord responsible for
keeping the fighting game genre alive
and a proud member of the what's up
PlayStation dot-com nation welcoming
back into the realm of the Lord's mommy
so Jay Bari
how are you doing sir hey know that
intro right there you almost intro right
mom you came up before the intros on the
podcast you know after that kind of is
your eight-day respect game and respect
but yo what is good everybody Nancy boy
Jay Bari yes all right gonna iron Lords
podcast man we're gonna be talking about
it man it definitely want to be a movie
this episode because you know play
fishing experience is going on a lot of
stuff with Game Awards and yeah man
that's overall it's good to be a
PlayStation game yeah
of course we have the usual suspects at
the round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother and the how of the
young wolf starting a new job this week
mom made Lord addict how are you doing
sir pretty good just uh just chilling
about to talk about this empty play
session experience
game award the solo game of who lives
with the single plain selfish experience
it's probably bit more online profile
incognito this week I've been off Bobby
Lord solve it how are we doing sir
Sharon man doing good man a little
disgusted at boxing last night but I
like I like I like King get into that
and I'll just jump in but uh you know
the funny thing is these guys got the
PlayStation guns out and the funny you
think about it like oh Jesus he's coming
into a more I would say like all the
lawyers have places now not like last
time he was on last time so you should
be in a warmer more comforting
environment
now Jabbar plays more Xbox than probably
most of us people people were posting
those you know those emails that
Microsoft's ins have to tell you how
much you played Xbox this year you had
more Xbox time the most Xbox hardcore
players I know now stop put that a light
I mean I mean when I when I was when I
had an ex but I was on titanfall right
like that wasn't my game you know I mean
that's why if you guys in like
Rosaria group bang bang I was like yo
they set up a lobby lobby was running
though he's talking about that was the
only way to play titanfall and of course
the excess gamer oh the lord of combat
sports was a man of his convictions and
demands nothing less than that premium
experience
mmm be love it love a king
how we doing sir we are doing very
disgusted stomach is like our own Noah's
like yo you ever got so crock city was
like I don't even wanna go outside look
at my car but you go outside he was
worse than you thought oh god like
automatically your legs are 100 million
this is a million less last week was
great fights you had Bellator fighters
you had UFC fighters and you had boxing
matches but I'm not gonna get it today
I'm gonna give it to one boxing match
very specifically because this was the
boxing match that was uh this is like uh
Halley's Comet you understand you had
two gold medalists that had two gold
medals of peace that was representing I
don't care how they got here
representing their countries in our
country now you had one that was seemed
looked at as the golden child they had
all the advantages and you had the black
sheep of the family that everybody
wanted out that always had it hard no
matter what that always had to preserve
it I always had to push forward and this
was his fight he chased this guy he
bring down first
what's the black sheep do Nikhil ball
rigging down my Cubano brother
Shantanu kuba kuba is he was the
pinnacle of cuban box and he represented
cuba boxing even though Fidel Castro
turned his back upon his brother he swam
to shark-infested waters
not once but twice people hmm to get out
to defect to get out he got caught the
first time and he had to go back do you
ever don't choose to leave your mom's
house you said some real foul stuff but
the place where you gonna go wasn't
ready for you so yeah go back he felt
we're baking Fidel no I'm going on a
little bit because let me tell you guys
I can't understate this too much this
was what Floyd versus Pacquiao was
supposed to be this you know when you
had a master boxer versus a master
defensive boxer you thought that you was
going to get that show now I don't care
I don't I don't care when you strap up
when you put your your gloves on and you
walk in that ring I don't want care
about how much money you made I don't
care about how much that guy weighs I
don't care about if he's the a side and
you the B side I don't care how bad you
feel about one thing when you put your
name on the dotted line this death
before dishonor thanks it's I don't care
what's happening you died there in that
ring because I used to lay something
glows mmm when I put that mouthpiece in
I'm going into a high-speed car crash
and I'm going in with both eyes open to
knowing that this one punch might be the
punch that paralyzes me or I might you
know push me in the head I don't see
anymore
and it happened to a lot of fighters but
this fighter in particular has a radical
father here he had 200 in his name and
he went in a he talked trash
Philomath saying go for hole yeah got
into the fight the first round ring Adel
one after that Loma Chang will be seated
to box the brakes off this dude I am
talking about
it wasn't no disrespectful box a little
breaks then it was best moving his feet
throwing his hands mm-hmm he got so
basically do got more like got
frustrated he knew that he's out here
with one shot he knew that this might be
the night that I'm gonna go to sleep and
its own might go and instead of you know
when the going gets tough the tough gets
going yeah boy folded up like a lawn
chair my god to my horror it wasn't no
it wasn't a Roberto Duran quit it wasn't
please don't say that and beat Sugar Ray
first before he came with an oh my
swollen belly excuse please
this brother quit this is this is
unprecedented to have a never lost so
much respectful fighters so fast nah man
listen you get into that way circle you
it's the refs job to stop the fighting
you go out on your shield you give
everything you can to the ref with the
Express you take your ass whippin like a
man
Lord sovereign understands and listen if
we were sitting in the same room he
probably should the same tear at the
same time we thought that this man
if he had to go I don't if his eyes both
his eyes was closed and he took enough
shots that he was beat up he was humming
I understand where you're coming from
Forrest Griffin back in the day for some
both two broken arms and still one but
hey if the dude felt like he couldn't go
on I mean he could had a severe
concussion it was and it's like you come
look at worse get your was like seven
years is jr. something like everybody's
Floyd like you know what take the L like
a man too long a subject but you know
what is to a lot of times when
undefeated dude knows about to happen
he's never faced that sometime they
panic he could have panic sorry I sound
like what you say that he he knew it was
all he was getting blocker need oh I got
to see this funny
we saw Roy Jones get stretched
- true - cross under my man getting the
shoulder Treach be courtesan anyway
shout out to the dude that broke them
other men heart when it comes down to it
he might he just might not have the
mentality for they might need a
different place oh wait for four hundred
times and lost twice oh well and of
course realness over here we ain't
quittin over here dial P now telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hit so before we get into what the
Lord's are planned you know even though
a little bar he's been on the show
before you haven't done it with the
right format so I want to start off with
law bars video game system history and
of course what led him to the creation
of the online arcade and that amazing J
bar a YouTube channel sorry what was
your first system was it always
PlayStation nation from day one out the
wall what was it oh now my first like
home console was you know I was born in
Jamaica so when we can uh I know the
first gaming thing I got was a tiger
hand here we put in quake we got
Nintendo
I pretty much I pretty much had I was
like a Nintendo Sega dude before slave
facie now I was a huge Sega fan like
Safeway I wasn't in lunchroom arguing
back it up heads good so what was the
Sega jury you had like if you run me a
first one we could remember it was the
genesis the original Genesis
yeah the first game it wasn't with Sonic
that we had it was the Tasmanian Devil
game and I know love yeah you're the
animation that that yeah the finding
from all that I now I respect it
dude the but yeah man with a huge fan
man and that don't hey guys figures got
me really into you know RPGs but I play
yeast things like ye ever RPG not King
wasn't that like wasn't it on turbo
graphics 16 years I say this indeed I
remember being like a disc heavy disc
game or some may be a correct me if I'm
okay it wasn't it it was one of the
first ones with an orchestrated uh like
it soundtrack or something like that I'm
used to being crazy yeah true JRPGs
first when it came out on turbo graphics
CD it was on turbo duo CD first and then
you know if they brought it over here I
played it a plea Japanese and got to the
end I ended it actually got it was
beautiful it was a beautiful game have I
still got my terrible and I think
correctly from row to look I'm not being
in your crib and I think I was kind of
like one of the early games like JRPGs
like voice acting continued Jaguar on
its journey so from Genesis yeah jennife
a Super Nintendo
Emma if my eyes really opened up okay
when the law of left knee that way with
that man that's that's when I really
really got to like fighting games and
that was like one of my you know best
RPG games like you know run amazing RPG
games on there but yeah I really my
favorite fighting game of all times on
that's that console Marvel classic
heroes and I used to play that game so
much remember the the new the new
Playstation I came out a little mini one
and I like the little LCD TV that you
can attach to it I sit around with that
with Marvel vs. Capcom 27 302 the number
one train and they are there you gonna
play this right ultimate ultimate battle
22 Dragonball Z game and my MA my Asian
dude he took me all the little imports
like legends because we all new yorky
let me ask you low bar did you know
about the connects downtown for the for
the early games back in the day or when
you let your face we're not even ain't
about to go that far you know me well I
don't for them little mom-and-pop side
right in the corner with cross paths we
probably just didn't know each other but
those who are spots man yeah and then
get them early still you stay
PlayStation sense now during that period
where the Xbox even attempt to sneak it
or we stayed away from it like where was
much like when he came to Xbox like the
exit of original Xbox I never had a
reason I Xbox well I had a lot of
so I mean at the time when I was in
college around that time that's what I
used to got into the halo and on some
uses play like you know split screen and
all that stuff their dough never really
like I never really got an Xbox into 360
early college that's you know things
happen where you know red rings and
reason why I got off I'm at issues in
you know college that you will really
get numbers like that so VAX
I had I had an Xbox for I had a ps3
because of me - because I didn't know
the difference between like the core
bundle and like the premium sure I was
happy that I got that this core trash
that you know I mean you had to buy all
these add-ons us to get official and
then was when he gigabyte hard drive
once it messed up that's when I went to
places I was on the basketball team and
we got a refund check back when I went
to the mall right here's the you a New
York talk cake in that direction you
went to the waiting and loving arms of a
Playstation I mean I mean I always I
couldn't get it that first year was too
much like miles waters get Xbox but when
I got that ps3 that day I got a ps3 I
got like six games I got an iPod touch
different on the basketball team so we
forget like I still had a news on that
but you know
when ps3 never looked back the Xbox
after that until the Xbox one funny
thing about it Xbox one I've bought more
Xbox ones than ps4 you know I had three
Xbox the original joint with a Kinect
the leap bundle and the S you know
you're one of the people make fun of
right the people that know the crazy
thing about the reason why I bought that
much Xbox ones is because I really
wanted to give Xbox a try and each like
each box that I bought it was a fix for
issue that I had with Xbox and I mean so
the leap bundle because it was the I
don't know how people with gaming on
Xbox in that controller because owns
crate I was like yo I can't play tomb
raider right now because it's dead zone
I bought the elite bundle because you
couldn't get like a leak control at that
time by itself so right that was the
easiest way to get it because the
controller so that's how smart the lead
control that was that was good but he
did fix the dead zone issue yes
fine-tuning on that stuff and then I was
like s I mean I just bought that cuz
that was a good-looking console but with
the new consoles right now I can't do it
man that's already three right yeah
that's really good right there yeah I
don't have an Xbox magistrate in that
pro oh I was very I'm still mad and if
just January alone you Xbox switch
whatever no will compete whoa oh we go
get it - whole horizontal bar hold on oh
you ready I'm online yeah what a get it
all and I want to get into after before
you know
one into your top five game franchises
so that's the new LP so what's your top
five of all time oh yeah
the top five franchise are the specific
game either or whatever whatever comes
to you all right well I do I do like the
first two is gonna be franchising so
much franchise of all the time it's fine
a fantasy that outweighs anything out
there in my opinion um I love Kingdom
Hearts as well so that's output that as
to definitely put metal gear up there as
well yeah expecially for metal gear 1
and 3 I love those kids
it was my I gotta ask you a quick
question real quick
Lord Yubari yeah the answer to this
question is going to determine where we
stayin of course mom do a little bar
let's go
sorry but yeah I kid that is an
acceptable answer
ok meet with me when I say 7 I can't I
can't give you like a two-hour
explanation of why I say 7 over the rest
you know I mean a lot of people will say
like 6 live he will say like 10 or not
you - truth fury on right yet - yeah
good I also love on for final fantasy
fourth one my think I like those
characters that's complex and that's the
reason why I love fine fine that's why I
final fantasy in general is good is
because they have complex characters
that and they always had that you know
what the hell moment that you know you
didn't understand nothing till they
yourself a committee to chase it Lord
she parties a traitor how dare he but
trace the mention oh man getting rough
outside for a few of them but you know I
can't but that's nothing my favorite
like okay this out - Oh Lord the lab on
the chair potentially perfect he's
saying Final Fantasy crystal Chronicles
he said fight them if y'all want that
work yeah Final Fantasy
we got what with both the other ones
ones you get the bride in part in the
march here salad okay give me two more
so yeah for definitely Marvel cation
franchise at five all-time this is a
game to come out or view their new one
is announced or what one of the original
titles you you gonna play it I'm gonna
be on it you're gonna be on it got make
that tough choice right you know I'll
put a spot yeah I'm action to see what
your heart said Dragon Quest my soul I
would bet my soul that Nintendo would
have been up in your top 10 that's how
five lists and they didn't even make it
you have played a lot of games like um
like Nestle Nintendo games like you top
ten yet like Zelda I love their yes I
love like Metroid things like that but
top five like games that I'm just gonna
like Dragon Quest like drank worth game
come on I'm playing it a say by Final
Fantasy game come out I'm playing a set
you know I mean Capcom you know we have
some struggles with infinite but I love
that you know franchise a mixing it up
in it I love it I'm a Marvel vs. Capcom
and I I played it in his true form and
the Sega Saturn
you know just trust me it's classic oh
yeah absolutely
I remember those fights well because I
before I didn't play like two on
Dreamcast my boy had Dreamcast who's
like a block away from me inside my
Dreamcast version better than that so
then you transition now and then we get
that the channel going so let's start
off with the UM the Jay bearish on like
how did you just get into the YouTube
game
what got you inspired uh what got me
really inspired was I was I was in a lot
of these you know Facebook groups on you
know on Facebook like the gaming groups
like entire group yeah this other group
called um gaming battlegrounds it was
more like those fanboy groups they go
back and forth arguing and this and that
so a lot of things out saying you know I
just wanted to create like a platform
like okay I'm saying all this stuff in a
Facebook group let me just create a
youth everybody gotta use I mean have
created youtubers get my my thoughts out
there I'm not as Savage outfit people
who I just don't care like you know
especially if I know some I don't want
to have like a conversation conversation
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna troll you
or you know go in like you know you know
outlandish things but uh you know
YouTube I try to keep it a little calmer
why does definitely want to get my
thoughts out cuz at the end of the day
what really really inspired me to
youtube is that a lot of people just
like to speak on opinions you know it's
all about its opinions opinions well a
lot of people have their opinions but
they don't have the experience they know
you the same stuff that's a saying why
don't you just try the damn game out you
know a lot more facts did you play it no
you didn't play they play
yep that's what I'm already muted two
persons mentally like I can't yeah so
one of my one of my things is like
always showing like always saying like
my opinions and my thoughts and stuff
but I'm also showing you the game how it
works in those gameplay in the
background side that's why I always
stayed true to showing gameplay
and videos and all that stuff because I
really like to actually see I hear what
you think well actually want to see it
as well like visually so yeah so that's
what really started my mom my Chan I
didn't really know too much playstation
channels like that a lot of before you
know my channel Inu a lot of like Xbox
channels and these guys were giving like
PlayStation news and I'm like why am i
what am i listening to these Xbox like a
hardcore channels has given PlayStation
news to try to you know convey to the
however they wanted you know moldy to to
gain an Xbox sale or whatever so I was a
fight now if I like PlayStation out the
so by placing myself and catch on and
listening what's up and now the other
thing I want to commend you on was
definitely the creation of the online
arcade because I think that if for us
especially should have to look our boxes
when the channels like the fighting game
genre is like one of those things that
was kind of teetering and we come from
that so just to see you kind of pushing
it forward you doing tourneys you
getting dudes up in the grudge matches
like really respect that you know
someone's out there keeping the fighting
game genre alive so tell me about the
how that started and the passion for the
you know whole fighting games or stuff
like that it's funny how that started to
because one thing I always admired about
the Xbox community you and I go back and
forth of them crazy always had like
these game nights and stuff like that
you know like some type of unison they
had a specific day that they're gonna
play a game and stuff like that I was
like dance PlayStation dudes like yeah
we communicate but we're very like two
or so sometimes where we're always doing
our own thing right so I was like yo
fighting games very strong on
PlayStation so I was like I I created a
group called PlayStation nation
all-stars on Facebook so at first they
started off as like a PlayStation nation
all-stars liked ornament stuff fighting
game so I was just like trying to get
everybody together you know Street fire
was just coming out and all these other
games coming out let's do it toward me
and Street Fighter was the first
tournament that happened and you know it
was it was pretty good we had like 24
people that you know like Sony
you a check standing in the corner with
the tiki torch keeping the lights all of
the place like it's true because a lot
of a lot of people that's like you know
more more to them so I'm like that you
know myself I'm I could be to myself
sometime in on position book like
fighting games you know that's always
something that can bring a lot of people
together like you said like Sony's
predominately known as these great
single play experiences so like like
being saw was so like I teased him I
called like the selfish gaming because I
know he loves that genre and he kind of
Sony caters to that so when to see doing
the fighting game stuff kind of bringing
people together on that it's kind of
dope yeah so it was a more like I we're
gonna have like a PlayStation community
in the Facebook group but eventually the
more toward the miss that was happening
the more was growing and people was
accident for other fighting games I know
when you're gonna do guilty gear when
you go new BlazBlue and I it was this
year like around in June well you know I
got like you know three other people big
shout out to my man up truck gaming gave
me more persona amidst official VG I got
them together
now he's like yo let's do this unlike go
and call it online archaic or that's
what it is made you know online and
you're gonna gonna set up like arcade
where everybody can just you know fight
and play or when a different section
either tournaments though we're gonna
have like the basically we got
tournaments where it's gonna be premier
tournaments that's like with a big
payout with a prize pot okay okay yeah
yeah doing that Tekken um I had to jump
in yeah we actually actually did second
arm we did Tekken
in the summertime we did let me know
next when that's swing background 2018
where we got our premier tournaments
like some of the programs up and taking
them definitely up there yeah be look I
bike just off the booze get up in me
right quick I got it from test it was on
sale I was like okay y'all stay off a
pier for my right Michael definitely up
there it's gonna be a made Oh
but like we got we got on premier
tournament that's like the big ones but
we also got like the light version
tournaments where even though Tekken big
tournament is all the way back in Mako
there's a lot of fighting games a lot of
fighting games like taking light for
terminus that people you know me so we
can get to know people like oh so that's
you know you know I know
[Applause]
originally the online are king we
definitely focus on like PlayStation 4
cause I mean that's where like we look
at fighting games yeah you know if on
Xbox they might be other platforms but I
don't see like I even try to like gauge
like King Kong killer instinct I would
say yeah and you might want to do a
killer instant torment and like two
people responded yeah people with eyes
like anybody one doing Street Fighter 5
I got like 50 people fine not next year
we're definitely gonna try to expand
like on xbox and you know on the switch
so because like poking switch has two
shaders in the corner
- yeah the man is gonna be like a
premier if the developer is actually
playing again we gotta go we gotta see
no switch so many we I've been here I've
been here I'd like you when we started
this up like I've learned so much when
it comes to this online tour - miss
right so I have like a whole rule list
like there's a whole bunch of rules like
you're good like 20 some rules listing
off everything as far as like you'll
make sure it's you that's playing stuff
with equipment lag issues like we broke
it down where I feel comfortable enough
that if somebody signed up for me that's
gonna be the person that's playing in
the tournament but we're definitely we
got we got to see and we got a
definitely tested that's why I say
they're not gonna be premier but we
speak we expect what you're doing out
there man that's hot that's how I like
what's going on yeah maybe you guys are
interested though if you guys want to
find out for any other tournaments all
you got to do is head to 208 dot
challenge that is ch they ll o n GE comm
challenge you're gonna see this mm-hmm
somewhere 28 20 20 18 Twitter me start
up you can sign up for those just write
parts there already
um yeah man if you guys like what we do
you can support us as well absolutely
I'm in there for the target I got you in
the tech yeah yeah definitely backside
inversion whatever they want definitely
one that we got to do like a like a lite
version for me as well yeah absolutely
that's what's up that's J Baris journey
so we gonna get it to what the Lords of
plan started back up with long boring
again
so um what what are you playing I've
been playing this week specifically I
mean I've been playing this V no blade
chronicles - I I seen you
if you go see love I'm loving that game
mapping game at first I was a little
worried fun because the combat system a
little too simplistic yeah when they
added after years on there yeah head
lady good lousy no blade anything else
you can plan
oh yeah Marvel vs. Capcom infinite I
have been 7 mm I mean trying to learn
geese
I seen you streaming that I'm back on my
blood borne I mean trying to get through
this curse chalice dungeon and Monster
Hunter world's Man 2 beta that [ __ ]
though my bad very good we keep it for
the Lords it's okay slippers go ahead go
and download that Monster Hunter where
else is there's gonna be a great game
man
I'm definitely thinking it and a game
that I think a lot of people sleeping on
which one which is man cool
it's called hidden agenda it's a play
link game anybody until don't assume
massive games
well yo this point if you guys stream
you're definitely stream that man it is
a fun ass game to play man you gotta use
your your your phone though to control
everything but it's still fun so you
have like do you have like three people
with you or four people you can all link
up with a doll we've had the Lord addict
what have you been playing this week
I've been playing the Cyrus thing Lord
saw what have we been playing sir just a
little bit of the Osiris stuff I have
too much of it and then more Xenoblade a
little bit more Mario that's pretty much
it okay okay
oh and some Assassin's Creed
is Lord King when you've been touching
everything
um agents of mayhem I went in on my
shadow of war a little bit of cuphead a
little bit of Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
Oh yesterday uh injustice gods among us
to cinching the Hellboy up a little bit
trying to get him down pack because the
new dlc is about to drop for that and
also playing my destiny - I am so happy
yeah for me it's been almost a little
bit of Xenoblade I've been touching that
a little bit got that going shoutout to
our Lord whiskey just got his switch so
he was asking me what to get he also
picked it up so I made me touch it a
little bit more Oh as far as Xbox I
touched a little bit of cursor Osiris
but I get a chance to really rock this
week I really haven't been around but
I'm gonna try to get that blaze going on
later on today um saying and I shut out
what else I got I picked up almost whole
bunch of PlayStation games on sale this
week so I got home I think that no man's
sky
picked up the street fighter 5 that was
like I can pick that day I cap that no
man Scott cuz I always wanted to see it
now after all the changes see what's
going on with that the hell blade I've
been one there for a minute and all yeah
the Takeo cuz on yeah I wish out to like
about so in the me oh yeah shut up with
yeah I hit up myself I see yourself and
you the one that's champion meal I see
it on sale is it worth it and you were
like use like [ __ ] that's all you you're
gonna love it it's deep it gets complex
so I did that but I want to shout out
Lord card because um I wanted I was
gonna hold off on picking up Tekken 4
playstation just for the simple fact I
wants the X enhanced version and yo I
gotta get out my man Harada you I'll be
tweeting them obviously we be hitting
them every day like what's that like
they're completely mum as if there's no
X in his not even in development so that
gotta be a little fuzzy can be playing
taking on xbox
well we know the controller situation we
know the controller situation
well you doesn't want a competition as
well you know what kind of leave me over
to you guys little Bari is the fact that
you guys got that special feature with
the UM that the music you can put the
Alltech in musics too like the stages
and the Xbox one doesn't have that so
that's like the exposure yes I want to
play you know say Rock'em Sock'em do all
things to make names to it oh man so
it's like I had to do it so I'm like yo
shout-out to them on that but yeah
Harada Xbox what's up man yeah I gotta
get that old-school Japanese companies
and Japanese developers they don't know
what all my xbox and hey we wanna we
wanna pro it is pro his back I heard
this new friend reset like 1080p ohm is
my rocket they not 4k but I heard in
1080p is the same you know the original
piya fourth nine hundred approaches 1080
I'll take it seems like they like they
glazed it in basses on a screen 20 yes
yeah yeah I mean it it's it's this no
it's just whatever the regular the
upscale is we know with your TV doesn't
what the system goes beyond there is
nothing me and it looks go boy it's
emphasized even worse now that we have
force that's why I couldn't do it and I
was like I gotta get the the PS won't
want until I hear so I'm getting else
you know the problem with that is that
you know you have the system you have
the capabilities and
the developer had the tools you know
this is the one point where I will say
to the developer then you had the Unreal
Engine and trust me the Unreal Engine
can scale up yes hit the scale yes very
much it nests we don't get into before
you can see top you got the the ILP poll
you're saying that was last week the
people results are in the people have
spoken
so the question in the wake of the pub G
framerate controversy if the Xbox when X
is capable of pushing 60 frames per
second in a competitive multi play a
game when the Xbox one s is unable
should a uniform frame rate 30 frames
per second be used the winner at 80% in
the most voted most argued three-way
ever on ILP is the no parity Xbox one X
is a premium product group came out
smashed apart they would loveless
they're covered in second place and only
15% was the yes parity must be kept free
Xbox one S group sorry Lord addict and
third place 5% was that I don't care I'm
playing Xenoblade to grow plus we
participated in the poll the turnout was
late what do the Lord's think about this
shadows let's table re as far as the
Xbox one I mean people one Xbox one X
being a premium product with 60 frames
per second no parity even if the Xbox
one s like of pop G if let's say if it
it is 60 frames and the eschaton yeah I
mean I'm definitely with that but I can
also see the issue with it yeah
with it being you know having no parity
because your big install base is on the
smaller side but if you bought something
for that much then yeah you wanna you
want to get all the bells and whistles
for it so I I definitely agree with no
parity on it yeah well it was intense
man a lot of good arguments and all
shouted Lord X bar he's in the chat I
know he was wrapping it with Lord addict
honest
young as far as the parody and stuff
like that so we definitely understand
what they say from a competitive
standpoint I don't agree with you know
Xbox guys calling people with essence
like what did you feel about the poll
he's still holding firm yeah I feel you
oh that stay tuned we don't get into
these topics know what you had an
experience that happens this week so
this is what I get for calling play PSX
out calling it my topic I'm like hey
season's gonna drop some hot stuff let
me get on this early it was a bit of a
snooze fest so it has been it's still
going on it's some stuff going on um I
said it before like oh like that was
their premiere show even more so in the
e3 and I I don't get it like for me
honestly they they just need to focus on
e3 and PSX is trying to get bigger
bigger every year and it's like they
want to hold it down I would just say
Rocky III make PSX this whole blowout
thing where you you you blow the roof
off of everybody's off everything in
show everything that you want to show
the 2018 and beyond
I just think base is gonna really be and
really be paying attention to it I don't
know Paris games week game Gamescom I
don't think they need that so um it's
low-key you know okay um so going into
the like the big stuff right um we
didn't really get release dates normally
stay forgot war
we have a release date for um Shadow of
the Colossus which is early February I
believe right have anything concrete
release wise for four days gone we
Detroit has no date either they saying
that it's coming um God of War saying
Detroit I don't think has a date per se
they say the 2018 would you be a spring
night war same thing no date so um that
sort of stuff like I was expecting more
night outs expecting something concrete
so that was a little bit disappointing
in that regard in terms of the big
releases in terms of like new stuff that
they talked about they doubled down
again on that VR um I have to say I had
hope I'd held off on it be I what is
gonna be my Christmas and last birthday
present this yeah I was jumping I'm
gonna get bad 350 bundle I'll have
impressions on that in a new year um the
medieval remaster that was cool for all
the old school acts of ps1 heads who
played medieval I know Lord kobato he
loved that back in the day like I was
saying the VR stuff like oh the the
treacle thing with The Last Guardian the
wipeout stuff prepare to vomit playing
wipeout in VR but that that stuff was
cool um the Mega Man love oh the Mega
Man love doesn't make a man in the
monster hunts I have to say was cool man
Mega Man began some love after getting
shafted for years and that travesty that
was a mighty number 9 I was like this
would mighty number now I was supposed
to be exactly so so in terms of the big
stuff yeah it was a little disappointing
I was expecting more um small stuff
though they always sort of bring it when
it comes to PSX and as it should be
because they it's completely PlayStation
static so you want the entire you know
to kind of attack the entire catalog
so I talked a little bit more about
Patapon um a bunch of other VR games
should be fruity you know smaller games
so waka Meili - ya know Judy fruity a
lot of VR man a lot of VR they get a
doubling down on it so I'm happy about
that that they did not backing away from
me particular question for Jai Bharat
Bharat did you see that omen of sorrow
that fighting game I know there's a demo
out yeah I played it haven't got it yet
how busy that looks it looks fantastic
it's a little rough it's a little rough
right now you could tell like this is
like way like pre-alpha stuff certain
things they got a fix on it the grab
range is way too long yeah you know
different little things I feel like you
need a little bit more touch it needs a
little bit more pop up in the background
it definitely needs like like a nice
firm and like a sound it just need his
own like personality to for it to even
do good but we're gonna look a bit it
reminded me nothing
it reminded me of the games they
reminded me a sort of the SNK game why I
like to look at the kind of drew me to
it yeah yeah yeah it has it has I think
a Mortal Kombat kind of feel it's a mix
between those two as far as movement
wise but it definitely needs a little
rough on the edges you could download
[Laughter]
the demo but not a one game I guess like
we did the interview with them they mad
cool as hell man but I keep it real with
them man how about that game if that
game came out today online it's gonna be
a it's gonna be a mess because he was
grabbing on wake up
all day so they gret what they blow bar
they grabbing down a backlight buddy yo
the grab range is crazy and then gals
like to compete I'm like wait either
you just grab me out of out of special
like what is
Oh easy right like crazy the character
characters you can play is pretty dope
though but it does feel like though the
fluidity needs a little bit work that's
the it doesn't need a pot it looks good
I think a needs to it don't pop it does
look like a generic fighting game but it
needs its own personality for it's a
drive no doubt so else all stood out
some for the European sack so back to
the like the coolest stuff Media
Molecule finally came back with dreams
and it seems like they got away from
that uh that that scary-looking Jim
Henson like fever dream heart style that
they had before it looks a little more
inviting now they talk a little bit more
about ghosts of Tsushima a little bit
more The Last of Us so let's get into
the format what people who were not
happy with with the format I mean the
panel stuff all that panel stuff is
great especially when it's the event I
have that in lieu of having your press
conference with the big reveals in the
trailers as the ha Christ like it's like
they they chose one over the other and I
think they need to expand a whole
experience and have both of those things
and had this be their blowout show for
the year even bigger than III I would
say I mean and that's that that was a
beef I would I like the panel's I like
seeing behind the scenes stuff I like
you know having Cory bar laws on stage
talking walking people through you know
what was going on and God warned stuff
like that that's all fantastic just not
instead of gotcha gotcha trailer Thanks
so if I have it let's get a lot barri on
one we got PlayStation nation in the
building we need it from the source how
was your impressions the PlayStation
experience and will you stand out titles
as well if if omen authoritative
experience with horrible agree with the
whole panel thing because like
PlayStation experience you're going like
the show floor and stuff people come
there you have the choice if you want to
go to the panels or play the game like
the whole the whole weekend is gonna be
a whole bunch of panels
so I the idea I didn't expect them to I
know there's gonna have a different
format but I think it's gonna have these
these panels and devs talking about the
games and you're not really giving us
real information about the games anyway
like you came out there Cory Balrog
respect this guy loved this guy to death
but he was an [ __ ] door now yeah
we're taught it pissed me off like I was
worried which one is core I forget which
one is that we've got a war arm he was a
little like the one with the red the red
sneakers you're the first question [ __ ]
sounds of fish único fisherman knows
anybody want to know the hard core
question when is this game coming out
you saying that we know if they play
test mode right now where they sending
out these demos if you do test out
science stuff whatever whatever
that's almost he almost done with this
game you know I mean the game is pretty
much done you just play testing stuff
that's the fine light little bugs and
all that stuff so where's the [ __ ]
release I mean do ask a question when is
this game coming out my man is if
answering man condescending and arrogant
oh the dog ate my release it what
throughout all the way you know from
wherever to chat like I see when you go
a little bar because it's like he's
there but if you remember like the what
is it the horizon zero dawn Dev next to
him was almost like why is quarry here
he needs to be working on his game
that's my do to harm oh yeah
why am I here on this your game is
already out we don't need more
information about horizon you got your
game
twenty minutes about stuff that we
already know okay good he was happy yet
his feet up he was relaxed gave us
finish places yeah but you know things
came up with family and I had to have to
cancel my ticket I mean my plane ticket
you know can't for the hotel all that
stuff they still got my sixty five hours
for the early bird but you know that's
cool whatever but
and the day if I went out there and I
sat down there i all my New York who
came out because I'm not sitting up
there I came here to see spider-man out
of war shades gone you know go sistema
bring those deaths on there and talk
about your stuff nah you know me if God
of War is gonna come out there and have
a 20 minute conversation that reliefs
they'd better beat it better be there
yeah flying from all over the world to
go to this area you're not going to ever
it might be 2019 for you what pissed me
off even more when Detroit came out and
they had their they had a they had a
actual demo something right well it was
the same kind of you know from the first
trailer boy you say grim buddy right I'm
gonna tell you right there not to
starboard
sparring no Bari dad dad Detroit demo
was yeah that was that was that was
definitely liked it I definitely like
that I'm saying this is the point I'm
trying to get is go for it the fact that
Detroit is coming out later as far as
the Detroit say spring 2018 got a war
saying early 2018 how the hell you over
have like a new demo or some to show up
or even a relief days but Detroit is
telling you at least you got a release
window you know me like spring and they
have a playable demo on a show floor god
award of have nothing on the show floor
you can just take a fresh you that's the
problem
all they had was Corey out there Corey
walking through the same demo from e3
and just giving inside behind and
talking about how the game is 35 hours
long which is fantastic but I just
something something's not right there
something's not right
yeah let's let's be real here they're
doing the same thing Microsoft has been
doing like it's like they have a thumb
drive that is with them and they just be
like here use this use this every event
use this if you know this is my issue as
well arm
I'm addict we had 2016 PlayStation
experience was lit you know I mean yeah
that job was everybody oh my god III was
crazy this is max if you want who the
hell came up with the rat's ass show
when you have had a show where everybody
had great reception with with see how do
you come from 2016 PSX that why this
happened I think I think it was the ex
they try to get some info out before the
ex and all this stuff that would have
normally there's a good was kind of late
it was October that normally you know at
PSX they had to drop the gun early just
to clinic get people to get off the crew
them cooled them down on that was even
even if you want to show the stuff on
past games and again you can at least go
into a little bit more detail with
because another to the rule when it
comes down to it it's like look I was
the most disappointed that we didn't get
a God of War release day if you want my
honest opinion uh Erica for the win Chad
I thought she said there wasn't even a
playable demo bear she's at the end so I
think that games getting delayed mmm
it's a huge L overall because at the end
of the day like the the show floor stuff
that's a completely different scenario
that stuff is fun you see the Bears
walking around you playing these games
but me personally if I'm going near to
the PlayStation experience I'm going
there to play specific games got a war
Dave's gone spider-man I want to play
those demos it's those demons are not
there is the L was right like imagine
playing um going to e3 and playing the
same demos you play to e3 at the PSX
like that would be extremely
disappointing imagine these people who
reported at e3 where they don't report
in PSA so it's the same demo there's
nothing really else to you know say like
that looks really bad
cause this report the truth that's all
and just like J bar is saying is saying
the truth you know and the funny thing
about it is like after after the our
thought that they had since Schumann was
like hey guys want to see some trailers
called donut County I was like I swear
to god yeah I thought it was like I
thought I gate that had a trailer begin
I thought it was gonna lead up to like a
major game cuz it was they was talking
my age do you have a platinum trophy
this is like a troll going into like a
retailer and then if the game was
actually you [ __ ] down thing for the
whole I'm on Twitter that of the god of
water section of PGX was more focused
around his son than actual Kratos then
they saying that's the biggest problem
right now that his son is having too
much dialogue and it's too much on this
little bit
wanna bet midway through this game
cradle stars mind that you know me
because a game but that's gonna make a
lot of people mad probably captured he
was speaking about that and he said how
like that trick a lot of people upset
that they felt that the kid had too much
banter and on you know he was saying
that I was almost demo day where he was
like testing play testing a demo of
implementing that tech cuz it was it
ready so to Lord addicts point it still
may not be ready because he's saying not
if they've scaled that back since that
an issue III trailer where I guess our
Paris games week when he was other kid
was talking too much so it I still get
the vibe they they're still he's crying
he look stressed man you know what
that's that's a crazy like like thing to
point out to people this is a young kid
we kids gonna be silent why his father
if I in troll this [ __ ] like oh yeah
absolutely you know I mean right now you
probably the Train of honest opinion I
think they intend on
were being around for a few years and I
think it is something yeah if something
doesn't happen here I think you know
Kratos might die at the end of this one
or at the beginning of the night you
know there could be different scenarios
Kratos could become a you know God of
whatever universe they're in now and
like he comes back as a god or something
like how much you want to bet to go turn
that to a revenge story and his son
because like goes to the same thing
Kratos that avenge his father's death
yeah my dad oh man I think that'd be
dope Kratos cradles hat yeah eight got a
war game Kratos man like you know Russia
but if you haven't in the bushes even
detail about that like give us more
information about the Sun or nothing oh
gee oh gee Mac and the cat says they're
gonna do it again war for I think they
can do anything better than what they
did in Gears of War for it definitely
the focus seems to be shifting was more
of a cinematic experience The Last of Us
kind of formal oh they can do a very
good job but they do it right if they
wanted to do something like that like
you know have it to where the next games
took place like 10 years later and
Kratos his kid is is grown and he's try
to avenge his father's death and he
starts getting help from you know what
are they in the Nordic yeah yeah I mean
he starts getting out from them I mean
Kratos couldn't even turn into a Nordic
god I mean there's so many different
areas that
can go into this don't listen to attic I
don't want that put that inside there
preview program in the bush let's get
your impressions of these BS X's I
haven't get a chance to meet to you
about this you know the best part about
that PSX experience your wild out dude
they were had you know the buddy morning
I was like yeah I just watched the rail
that that idea had just explaining
everything that was announced let me
keep it funky I don't care about these
dudes be honest with you um I I purchase
their games for the single play
experience when they drop they drop um
uh yeah I'm looking forward to guard war
yes of course I'm looking forward to
gays bonds and all this other stuff
um I'm hearing that all I'm hearing is
bad things from the show and it seems
like they pulled a Microsoft remember
Microsoft did that stupid format that I
hated that I Pam um and it was doing the
just to sit down panel and they had
those two women there that didn't know
what was going on yeah it was disgusting
and same way I was disgusted with them I
understand PlayStation people are
disgusting with this I feel you guys I
feel you guys pain and I have a pro
alright and I'm saying it to say that
when those games do come out I will play
them there's games out that you could
play but for people to fly out to go to
a show that they was expecting you know
you're hurting yourself because those
people had a bad taste enough they're
not gonna be back next year
alright and they're not gonna sit
they're not gonna blog about how
Rachel experience was because if J bar
is telling you and he's a Playstation
doing he's telling you I'm disgusting
with your I'm trying to get him to have
[Music]
a great year
you know me cuz I just I just can't
understand how you go for 2016
P a fix to this one Monday go ahead
let's be real here it's
switch you one week away from
Playstations start is starting to get
that arrogance man you need you need to
leave why why it's good when the
shipping I think oh is it said hashtag
bleep Xbox yeah got on a fan in January
alone ninokuni to thank you the video
you can plays those five euros just fine
games come in throughout the year then
he got my yell coming out then another
chaos go for a little too fighting no
I'm happy with places I just I'm gonna
subset that name like you have a more
critical PlayStation in than Microsoft
for Nintendo so you know it's like gotta
be that's why was a closer pfx was the
closer you had everybody anticipating
everybody asking these questions on e3
Gamescom Paris games week you sort the
closest this year out right this was a
great year for place if you close it out
badly with this show do you think
Microsoft got a UH the doors cracked
open loves it
yeah might definitely gonna slide up
with that fear thieves they drop that
release date the big gameplay fishing
yeah Microsoft at a release date for
their big game yeah you wait until next
year we got pub G next week
I have opened that open beta watch it on
Friday PlayStation experience I mean
it's weird because from an Xbox Fame
perspective I guess me I'm watching it
and I understand why everybody's upset
but I'm looking at it like Xbox stuff
doesn't do anything with it so I'm like
wow this is cool I get some background
information but a game or gives you no
time to sit down and stuff like that now
I know what a Sony guys are coming from
where the last two PS X's was like
really I'm saying so it could be a
situation where they could have just put
everybody's game with Paris gameshow
because that was right around the
conjunction of the Xbox one X launch so
I'm like okay they may it did that to
kind of block them you know to get the
Mancha yeah and they come PSX you know
remember then they had the game in
Sony's defense they had Paris games week
where they had it toward Xbox one X then
they had the game of what you got to
give the game award something right cuz
everything Jeff Kinney wants some new
premieres they want to get the crowd
hype so they did the DEF straighten out
there and whatever whatever now I don't
agree I agree with all adequate like
they can't be showing the same trailers
over you know I am NOT a fan of it I'd
make the same boss that you spit yes
Microsoft that worked when he did that
with Gamescom yeah we win any normal
Microsoft I think oh we like you cannot
be showing me trailers kiss show that
party is we're making a joke that you
know that's where I got the thumbnail
the thumb drive job we're saying feel
Switzer got that in his wallet
Kojima had on the Game Awards and then
bring it over to the PSX joint and be
like okay here it is without anything
you know for the most part nude it's my
size him coming out with the jetpack
thing on his back that's part of the
game and then bring him on stage what
was that about
oh we my first time I met you gentlemen
when I lost his game code at e3 I'm like
that's nice I don't have a bar talk on a
conference
is our check so d of like I don't you're
thinking like how does that even
relevant to this game like how relevant
to the Semitic I knew he was gonna go
left is when they had all them couches
and then you start to still realize it's
like three more couch spots laughs and
I'm they had the college dorm couches
movie even coming out
you could tell he look stressed gaming
ready you know and I mean tense defense
you know he was kind of throwing shots
back at the other devs like yo your game
finished like what you could the horizon
zero dawn do you know you know it was
just a lot of filler me personally I'm
such a Detroit become human family that
I actually like to see that demo neat
when they do showed it I think that game
is gonna be phenomenal
I'm very high for that showing that was
cool I'm saying like yo to finish it off
for the people that actually stayed up
to watch that yes I know Oh Detroit
become a human demo PSN store right now
go download that type of movement yes I
agree I agree and and it definitely
definitely wasn't that so I mean the
only other thing I want to shout out
more Kingo is that as much as I give
Sony a lot of crap when it comes to
peripherals and not supporting it they
are doubling down over y'all remember
remember guys I was remember when I was
on here and I love you know psvr gospel
yeah with every game they did me dirty
in the beginning for jumping out the
window hanging out with these guys they
are they definitely did me dirty with
the new system that they're coming out
with you know I was early after okay I
understand I know the problems with it I
thought it was just me having these
problems but and I got all ready and I
saw you know what was going on I'm not
gonna get rid of my system I said of the
week that I will get rid of it um I'm
not getting true value for so ever
rid of it it's a moment in time and I
was watching history being made that
Sony actually took that leap of faith
which they do a lot but this time
they're doing it a little bit
differently somebody's there that's
really pushing the rhetoric and they
wanted to get to that magic price of
like 150 that everybody can jump in and
purchase I see it's at 199 right now um
so once it hits that 150 critical mass
point you're gonna see the numbers rise
you have people that still ambiguous
with it because it's very hard to show
people the feel of it because you know
VR gives you a feel so um when when they
actually put it on their head it's no
going back to be honest with you yeah
you can you can play a little bit with
somebody else on something but if you
want that real selfish experience VR to
be the most selfish be seus person that
you could be because if somebody walks
in the room and you have this thing upon
your face you don't even need the TV on
and you're in your own world it is the
ultimate selfish experience and it's
beautiful first of all got it dresser
real quickly check out the micro boxes
bags he's a little upset that we had Jay
Baryonyx box how dare we and let me just
say this real quick like we had the
animals podcast we support games all
platforms so at the end of the day like
we respect what everyone's doing out
here and even if it's not your platform
of choice we're not gonna sit here and
bash it so sorry you feel that way you
do right there the official like hater
of like me basically this is not you
know say anything personal we respect
everybody from all platforms so I made
videos about me like you know me like
you don't even know what I do like he
won't watch my content you making videos
about me like if I thought you make a
video about me you know
I'm doing did you go understand that's
beautiful I wish I had a stand I mean I
think that encode dude is my stand might
be box to come on like I know and we
shout out to Disney and the crew he
rocks with them if he wants to come on
he wants to you know say some points in
respect but you know all that I'm not
supporting because somebody has another
platform we're not down with me when
that when I'm like everything I state
like you know I'd say everything also a
experience that's one thing I believe in
the heart you know me actually you can
have your opinions but experience
outweigh opinions all date so when I
make my you know videos on Xbox and
stuff like that it's not me that's blue
you know the same whatever I want to say
that's the hey Xbox I had three times a
number I'm talking about be fair though
there are two Jabbar he's Lord bar your
Twitter's probably micro bulk effects is
history oh yeah oh yeah yeah if it's
bang bang who's mad at me I remember
wise man I remember he's a big man he
made a video about me whatever mentioned
yeah okay so let me jump in or des
training is like is this is you know
what this is and they said the laulima
Ilana each could Jean I'm not surprised
as like is one of them thing the only
thing I'm concerned about like to be
honest you actually like what I saw I
don't know what was going on I like what
I was
is the only thing I'm concerned about is
that kid like la douleur katsu kijima
gone Kojima right at the end of the day
my concern is you got Norman Reedus and
your history has shown it you blow
budgets so Bob his concern if they gave
him the open pay cuz these were the part
of the reasons why him economy had to
fall out you know I'm saying but honey
I'm gonna get it I liked what I saw it
look weird
it's vintage kijima I like oedema
witness weirdness but the thing about
Kojima is it's like he you know what it
is like he'll take you over dramatize
the simplest thing and make it seem like
it's this big deep concept bread like
that he just takes these small little
concepts and it turns it into this
overly complicated thing so I just I'm
sure is gonna be fine I just don't know
what this story is gonna be okay have we
not have we not at all put the
perspective that maybe
Kojima's previous employer had painted
reality no right and that's what I said
number what I said no budget do you get
games maybe his previous employer when
he was talking about making these
bizarre you know no one knows won't
confuse games they're like yo that's not
gonna work when normos readers still do
play in the game was like I'll have to
look on the internet to figure out what
I just watch says a statement like that
I don't have to just go ahead like you
know what the difference between right
now in five years from now is right now
death straining is the biggest B I'll be
game for PlayStation and five years from
now it's gonna be the reason place they
should don't do [ __ ] with him anymore no
all I see is them spending all this
money and literally it doesn't look like
this game is
an inch since the last time we saw it
yes labarie what's your feeling
definitely so I think I mean it looks
cool but I don't know what's going on
either I can burn things like that he
had that's like the health meter went
red you know shout out shout out to
dreams your dreams gone but uh like he
said oh no gate guy I think I'm gonna
say you said they said that it reminded
him of metal gear and I just sit here
like did we watch the same thing gee
buddy say the part when he was going
into um the water and he said that was
gameplay Blake check for six years and
blow the budget of hell made early
trailers something showing awesome
gameplay like I want to some concept of
what you actually hi it looks he's
probably gonna be third person shooter
but he's still you know they they
definitely did say it was open world but
you know shout out to kids but he's like
for all we know this could be a hard TS
is a quiet a version of cliffy B let me
say this right because there cliffy
being standing on the mountaintops
proclaiming his game was going to be the
next comment of this the Lord and um he
had to get smack down to the basement
and to the bushes get out and get into
the bushes and go humble yourself
Nakajima has gotten a blank check now
everybody felt dead Konami was wrong
area right and let's take it from this
perspective because what I saw was I saw
a guy getting high off his own supply
I saw this guy that's over there he's
taking his friends and he's allowing his
fans to blow his head up that you have
to grease the doorways to get him in the
world
this guy is not walking on water
brothers the game looks like crap that
stuff looks like crap because it's not
real I'm not about the lies because
remember what he was showing with with
Metal Gear and then what you actually
got no I go way back with the la Li Li
la Lu and I had to look up when I was
playing the game because today's old and
what he's doing is he's telling this is
highfalutin trolling they sure gonna buy
my stuff no matter what because my name
is labelled on it I saw shadow the Panda
shout out the Panda I saw a grown woman
cry tears in her eyes because he was not
at a spot that he said he was gonna be
on Twitter yep yes and this is the
problem weboost these guys are too far
into the stratosphere without games you
know dude is your last game Metal Gear
sucked okay so let's get that clear
Metal Gear suck that was your game I
don't care what you're saying that these
guys they shut your hand off and cut
that budget no mr. blank check over here
is this is black baby goo was black
trust me it was no game play they're
garbage not to my camera to chase a
yesterday on PSX I don't know if this
true suggesting on PSX they said Andrew
House just Auto approved conceived was
budget without doing the typical
approval process most games goes no no
chemo kijima got auto approved because
they basically using a Sony engine you
know I won't be playing at
you know he's not creating his own
engine he's not like oh so to give me
money I'm gonna create my own engine now
you're using a Playstation and you can I
stay something like I know I'm probably
not I'm gonna get jumped on for this
statement but uh have we not considered
the fact that Kojima might need a
straightjacket don't say that to Geoff
Keighley gloves are off like like the
gloves are off like now if you the check
is blank and he's gonna do whatever
craziness posture to the head he's gonna
try to fit it in today let's see why
this guy got fired like I'm really
starting to think Konami kept his dude
in line like he's like look like we like
your ideas but you gotta listen to these
people because sometimes you have it a
little bit is people saying they'll
toriel toriel toriel and associated
territorial is not gonna be wanna be
known with this guy in a second when
this game come out ten years from now I
said everyone losing their minds over
the stomach baby but it's an
over-the-top metaphor for the inner
child
end of story and damn you wanna defend
yourself this is the first like you know
me have a little mystery gonna have
everybody guessing cool but just let
your third truly show a little bit you
gotta be a little bit more simplistic
now like what are we gonna talk about
the demons that's in the ground
this is the blockbuster movie coming out
Eunice says straight-to-dvd we got the
money in to test the Soul Calibur yard
which everybody thought about so
callable we're all right in the labarie
what you think I never been like a Soul
Calibur like connoisseur but you know
I'm definitely all right experience so
[Applause]
we had some fun fun discussion and all
that good stuff we had a lot of awards
some great moments that popped off and
shout the law saw the promos for me from
everything you could think of let me
just say like like thinking about like
this dude show so much McDonald's it
wasn't even funny
it's like and I get you got your
commercials and you know you got you got
your advertisers but like I
felt like there was more advertising in
this in this game Awards there was like
announcements
listen gotta pay the bill shut up I
would do something I hope you let us
know it was it was one of our jump in
real quick I mean it was one of those
things that um first of all I want to
shout out Geoff Keighley I know he gets
a lot of crap but at the end of the day
it was I thought it was a very good show
I felt that at the end of the day our
genre has our Oscar so to speak you know
I'm saying like we've got something for
us no shout out to Joseph for me and I
do this on that sauce now that dude was
amazing I don't like it
you play this where gamers get the bad
name they be like look see these got
these clowns doing the talk and his talk
look at smallish and that's why people
don't respect he was funny for us I
laughed I thought it was hilarious
but if you looking from the outside and
you look at people who look at gonna
show if Queen it was very like he had to
get a mic to him and he Geoff Keighley
had the horror in his eyes
like he was being held hostage Oh talk
about a game after the trailers i nope
first I want to shout out to the crown
you Lord segment Lord solved with that
their tally thank you sir first of all
big up sister Lucy Lord Cognito for
winning the crown your Lord let me get
the final tallies and the tallies up
okay so cog in first with 12 points
yours truly in second with 10 points
Lord King with 9 points right behind
that you can you can call you for a
recount or something like that
right in front of Attica eight points
what actually surprises they actually
didn't announce the multiplayer game on
screen on show and apparent was pub G
but we all got that one right so it
wouldn't have me right much of a
difference you know saying on that John
but yeah that was a good one I voted my
water I didn't think they were gonna do
a cup of G would win it just to be
honest cuz I thought they were gonna
make it a popularity contest
but shout-out to Zelda the go what did
everyone think let's not well yeah what
did you think about the Game Awards
itself the whole no joy
I think the Game Awards worth as I say
was presentable so was clean it wasn't
like the mess like the vzx yeah
definitely boring though I I do feel
like someone get some games definitely
got slighted in either in their category
sounds like that horizons and talk no
not even horizon I like
I did I did a livestream saying my
personal game that you know you know I
feel like shall win in the category and
I who they're gonna pick to win and I
believe that whoever who's gonna pick
what you know they got it but um I felt
like some games got slightly man like
you know um best narratives they gave to
Eden Finch I didn't feel like that was
the best narrative which I gave it to
which would give directive to other
definitely gave me to like hell bleed
like was lit or even horizon I know I
know they're gonna be like oh yeah Rison
horizon had a great arm narrative
alright hey sorry to interrupt your coat
here uh let them see my that's when your
shows been taking over he's pretty he's
got the no no please no Moyes you
looking for me to do the same outlandish
crap every year now it looks like he
wants to literally put his arm around
him and push him back pushing them off
he's like get out of here with that crap
I've worked really hard for this show to
be successful was neo that's actually I
mean who cannot was grace that was yeah
for the action but come on I think
Wolfenstein won another one too man I
want to I believe come on let's be real
here huh but not other than that I felt
like you know whoever wanted they wanted
I was as happy pub Jean when game of the
year thank God thank God gaming was
saved offer that Bank Zelda fell there's
a great game no denying that I don't
think it's the best game this year
but it was definitely it's definitely a
great name it wouldn't it it is what is
it because the game of the year I feel
like every year there's like two or
three games that either one of them come
win in it and I would be okay with
gotcha
Lloyd King would you feel there was a
great show I honestly was a little bit
sleepy with this is how you know as soon
the war shows PSX but it was it was a
good show it's a nice show for us to
come out you know come out together so
we could with shooting dying it out
there I'm not that corporate dude I'm
not gonna tow that line know when to be
PC and when to be you know about it I'm
glad that guy came in and infused some
summer energy to with the crowd because
like he said this was his moment and he
stood up and he felt his moment and he
was very excited and he wanted I want
that game I really want that game but is
another game um get the F out look like
a it was made by the team a payday no
it's for the painted people to make it
and not the left for dead people to make
it speaks volumes it looked great it
looks it look like zombies or something
was coming and you set up turrets in you
must play together that's what I want
um if it's only on PlayStation I hope
not because I really wanted a true 4k 60
frames per second um so if we can get
that over there I'm definitely gonna be
on every day but that game I would do a
beta or whatever for that game I would
be in a preview program for that game
what's up no solve what did you feel
I got agree with Bari on this one with
it it was
everything was well presented it moved
at a brisk pace it felt like they really
had you know they knew what they were
doing now a couple years in they know
what they're doing even though felt a
little bit sterile um but you know it
moved briskly out and that was cool um
the fact this guy Joseph Ayers oh yeah
he was he injected that that little if
he might not let me finish we have to
limit that but um but that said like you
know I came to is good to finally get
the deserve the DLC the little the
little tease from from software saddled
likewise take exactly you know yeah you
know how they don't you love how they
tease something with from software and
everyone thought it was gonna come out
at uh what about bayonetta yeah that was
there yeah man together as a combo it's
a better like triple it sells on that
and then a game that was on Microsoft
stage at e3 they got a little more burn
with the Metro Exodus what real quick
what did everyone think about the the
orchestra stuff we've seen that a
blessing that we can traverse some
people love this alleviated it the one
the orchestra one like um yeah like Game
of the Year they had a play like the
music our person liked about was curious
I like the ending one where you know
they showed them all and first stuff I
didn't understand where the puppy won
games right no I was laughs I was like
what they gonna do for the orchestra for
pub Jesus I was curious
you had the hottest one because they had
to like bet me a game that it was Mario
because they're spending too long on
Mario and I was like oh get scabby I go
from Mario is what the orchestra won
Mario game of the year wellness Mario
dude what do you think about the August
real or King lobar would you feel I like
the man I'm a music I love music and
video games so that I'm playing that yo
I bought I bought an ear I bought that
not near but I'm horizon
sound Mario got a soundtrack on hikes
and I buy that too I just love that
stuff I thought it was dope is just kind
of if you're a fan of the genre you
remember those tools on what stage was
doing it what do you offer I agree with
the laws I did like it I thought it was
necessary for the culture which I think
he to cool that you would like listen um
what was that gates of thunder
soundtrack for turbo graphics when that
game came out so it's a lot of
soundtracks that you like shinobi
soundtrack stuff like that do I care for
it in the middle if a show filler that
was all it was it was show Phyllis oh so
you're indifferent more so not that you
hate that was a nachos moment okay
anybody else any other laws got anything
left on the game awards they want to
discuss okay going once going twice no
one's been ignored a couple of podcasts
go didn't look hard you know keep
forgetting floor sovereign like causes
I had a birthday party King put a
question though I do have one quick
question ago for what do you guys feel
about that uh
CDs release date I'm happy excuse me is
it an open painter isn't it supposed to
be open right now with this oh god I
can't stand these Millennials I think
what really wants to ask is what do we
think of the price point oh yeah that
really was good they always put a
triple-a game so yeah I was expecting
anything less than sixty I didn't expect
like you know for the most part when we
see games we know what we're getting but
it's like I feel like announcing a price
and a release date without showing that
content it's foolish like we literally
know nothing about this game we just
know it's a fire gaming you get treasure
60 straight off the bat is that he good
to see that they got the release date
but he says $60 he needs to see more so
he does agree but in lorca boss you
agreed on something xbox guys is very
hesitant with this game being 60 and
yang will have that much gain from let
that clip go let it go play pubsey next
week's it out most people
ask about me can you already ask for my
coming in here say you're borrowing it
so I'm that you had just stand jumping
said his piece and jumped out and he
probably had he's probably one of the
people that put there
yo you listen I'm not saying anything
against you this is the most hates that
we've had like them for yo followers is
no joke baby people that came in here
hit the dislike boring next week Xbox
know everybody said boring at the
shotgun to the final topic lord King the
curse of Osiris the least no you want to
talk about that what's going on in this
crucible strategy is it enough how you
feeling about this okay um let me give
you my raw impressive of it and then I
can't give you the impressions of the
rate stuff so I'm gonna have Lord addict
jumping on that okay
um because I was trying to get a team
together and I wanted experience with a
couple of people I didn't want to
experience it with other people come to
think of it Lord King if you would have
played with us yesterday like we asked
and not go watch that sports event you
would feel a lot better right now my
soul had me tied to that fight and my
soul was crushed so I'll take my little
whipping and I'm saying the corner cry
by myself um but I got to curse evil
Cyrus and for all you people that's been
talking about
baby they fixed a lot of the problems
that people was having they got a lot of
ornaments in the game to another space
to go to they gave you or more weapons
to collect more clothes to get that
another leveling system as far as
getting to what is it 2:30 I mean three
dirty um and the grind is back
shoutout to x-bar he's with me we were
doing it up it we had such a great time
shout out to look iPods ooh we were
doing it the strikes what I don't like
is this right and this is the problem
that I had with Sony writing checks to
people and for some people to do
disparity before the game got patched to
the 4k I was running it in pursue do for
K 60 frames per second now once I got
patched I got true for K 30 frames up
yeah okay it could do 60 frames per
second on eggs I know can but we're
being held back by Sony also the package
deal forces us not to get certain
strikes that Sony has with certain guns
that Sony has bombs
this has been the most lopsided
disgusting practice that I've seen that
you allow a year a year is a long time
for me to get a strike now maybe you
should have said okay well you're not
gonna get this strike but you won't get
this strike and then get this right and
we're flip-flop strikes the following
year but to keep this practice going
I'm calling out to EA I'm begging EA
since you're in bed with Microsoft I'll
double the price on our Sony's Luc rates
and content on our system for two years
before they can get it now back to
Osiris um
it's what it's supposed to be I'm you
could probably hit a smile on my face
you know because I listen
to everybody talk bad I I took it
um yeah it's a good begrudgingly I
fought I fought every step of the way I
left cleanse I stopped talking to people
I'm gonna be off my Facebook I booted
people off my Twitter I block people uh
for the simple fact I'm not gonna allow
you to sit there and give me that same
rhetoric about a game that I love and I
know it's good it's a good game is it
great yet no will it be great later
probably at the end of the run but for
you to diagnosis as D away or on arrival
because you don't like they didn't give
you something and you said the rest of
the game is trash then you never liked
the game to begin with but thank you for
your money and we're gonna continue to
keep it pushing dough down okay anyone
else first what anyone else get a chance
to play I've been all know pretty much
the latest week so I have not got a
chance to play much Lord addict
counterpoint have you got no you got a
chance to play a little bit right oh no
sleep oh look I'm not saying this games
bad I'm not saying this expansions bad
I'm saying that you know I I like the
expansion rate it's fun you know it's
really short
it's literally like four sections to say
first and second section are mad easy in
the last two or semi-hard but they're
not hard hard I got to the last part of
the raid and the night to go to bed cuz
of work but it's just like look like I
this part you know a right team I never
really played with you know shout out
the x-bow and all his friends but it's
like if I can guide you know this group
that I just met through the first couple
parts of this rape of no issues what's
every I'm like it's just not the rape
the raids I enjoyed from the first one
so like if they don't do something with
the second one I'm not I'm probably not
gonna buy anything else destiny related
so pretty you're you're right now that
after because you already in on the two
DLCs the first ones right but after that
second one about a second one if they're
not if it hasn't improved substantially
you you you it's a wrap
my baby I like the first one I did but
you know I mean I like the you know the
story a little bit but it's like the
story let me if you really want to break
this story down you go in the same
section of the game or over and over and
over and then one time you go in there
you fight thing to the antagonist of the
expansion I mean I feel like it was
sloppy I feel like the story was sloppy
I feel like there wasn't a lot of
interaction of Osiris I don't care hey
what in this chat ain't beat it and it's
just like what about the content what
about the content okay about delete mom
is right here you know when it comes to
race I really take his opinion when it
comes to the race very seriously um and
that's why I'm not attacking him on his
viewpoint on that because I didn't play
it like like you said Bari if you don't
play it shut the [ __ ] up right send the
Queen sorry sorry my French sorry Holmes
so I you know and I didn't play it so
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna sit
down and I'ma shut up I'm gonna hold
that in because hopefully I'll play with
him today because I know he didn't want
to play with me yesterday in on-post um
and I was like y'all I'm gonna watch
this fight but what I wanted to ask him
about is the content the new guns and
stuff like that because a lot of new
guns it's been released I was not Excel
very good I heard that it's not actually
feel exotic so that's that's what I've
heard I got like one or two of them and
they seem I like the guns I like the
concept behind it but at the end of the
day I'm in this for the raids that the
range is short it's fun I enjoy doing
the part I did but it's just like at the
end of the day you know I hate to
you know spoiler anyone in here calles
is talking like he did in the regular
Leviathan raid it's just like they throw
this random vex mine at the end of it
and you fight cabal the whole thing it
makes no say you continue with okay I
got you I'm a continuity standpoint you
just you know I was sitting there when I
saw it pop up I was like I'm gonna fly
in and just something different that
proof that shows why I would go to this
place yeah oh there wasn't even an intro
that wasn't in the original it just you
popped up like wow floppy this there's
laziness and I'm like you can't justify
putting maybe 20 guns in a game - if I
would have bought that and individually
be twenty dollars - a third of what the
Year oh the whole game is gotcha now let
me let me play devil's advocate for a
minute cuz have to look how about so and
she just need a chat there you go on it
we all know that realistically destiny
has a lot of problems right and they
still trying to fix these things but
realistically did we expect everything
to be fixed by cursing Osiris DLC or is
it one of those things that like you
know saying we want to give much I'll
see next week there's another update
there's another patch as more changes as
this is that January there's another
update there's more patches it's changed
this and that or is it one of the things
like yo it may be just too little too
late they've already pissed off the base
by where we at with that it's at the end
of the day sometimes it doesn't matter
what you do you you already lost your
following like even if they do fix this
the biggest thing I enjoy though you
know I don't take off for expansion
launches I take off for the raid because
I know I can still get my time in
because III play destiny efficiently and
not just a long time mm-hmm so it's like
you know what might take someone 15
hours I could do at seven or eight
because you know I you know for the most
part with feedback from everyone in my
my clan you know you Lord Lord David I
know what to do to efficiently get
higher level and not just take a long
time right so it's like I know I can get
this always take off for the rain
because I want to play the raid day one
right when it launches and it's like
even if that's what I enjoy guess what
you know that this might have been a
cool little experience but six months
we're gonna be right back in that will
yet gotcha
so your whole thing is you're not a fan
of raid leaders let's just call it right
now I thought that I'm a fan of the
concept but not replacing it for core
expansion okay barri I just got a
question
being that you on the PlayStation side
of it right now
and do you play destiny - on the
playstation side because I got to get a
perspective from those guys oh no I
don't I don't play destiny arm
I had Bethany one I was I was fully
charged I was fully with definitely one
I felt like - wasn't really that much of
me the purchasing right now
maybe I'll get it later on but right now
I'm just too occupied with all the
talker Lords self you've been quiet a
little bit I played a little bit of
Osiris with a with King and I'm not gone
by the way okay
a little bit but then I got in there and
I hadn't been there for a while so I had
you know doing my public events and
stuff like that so I have not had a
chance to sit down and continue playing
Osiris me I'm coming real quick before I
go back to attic yeah obviously I've not
been around this week so I only got a
chance to touch a little bit at the
launch I'll play a little bit blaze
through the story I mean I liked it I
liked pretty much I like to set pieces
are from the set pieces of beautiful 40
HDR is amazing past mercury I was loving
it I felt like no spoilers that we
should have got more Osiris interaction
I'm saying but that's all I just felt
like it was great and then at the end
everything was just like it wrapped up
and I'm like alright that's it
no saying like I was the war like was he
going like that God is so on obviously
I'm a big what's ours fanboy yeah check
my Twitter vote oh yes disappoint in
that respect not that the story was wack
it's just like it is indeed abrupt
and actually the last boss mechanic for
that was kind of hot and I got kind of
hype about that social space it could be
bigger for a little bit more of that you
know as far as the raid I didn't play
yet but I did peak shout at the Lord
cactus he's got a rate of my guide out
there right now I couldn't resist cuz I
know I was gonna chance to play and this
be the first raid I've missed in a while
so I said let me just see what's going
on and surprisingly the reviews I've
seen from everybody was really positive
everybody was like yo this is a really
good rate
you don't saying now they did say the
Lord acts point maybe like a little
shorter than the the most but they did
kind of say that you said but they say
in the experience the co-operative
aspect is lit you know they getting it
in there so that aspect I definitely
want to try I'm probably gonna jump in
with both feet on Tuesday because that's
the reset and that's when they doing the
reset of everything we get in the master
works with the weapon rolls we get in
the gifting to out the people nice and
thank you sir cuz I will be online at
midnight hundred right 100 yeah oh so we
could all be in the same get you pumped
you gonna be late yeah I don't know you
might do duo's I think like four people
in a party to work with
Laurie why don't you um today go out to
Best Buy pick up X bus eggs you can play
with us all day and we could be duo's on
this month I'm gonna be getting like a
like a gaming laptop so I can get
automating stuff like that so I will be
having my xbox stuff I'm like what is a
digital world out no child young Chris
in the chat yeah but that's pretty much
my dad me giving back
you said you have more to talk about
before red sticker so let's go what you
got when it comes down it's like look
like I want this stuff to do good it but
at the end of the day I just don't think
that they're trying to they're not going
the direction that I wanted them to and
it's like I said like what the problem
if I play destiny the stuff that I am
interested in it's all story and lore I
don't need to play the game for that
right like I can literally look up
cutscenes for an expansion never touch
it like that's not an issue it's like
but it was the Ray said that always like
I loved like even raids that wasn't the
biggest fan of like you know the the
wrath of the Machine was still amazing
mmm not you but this raid like it's fun
but it just makes no sense like at all
it it it's like they put the entry I
feel like this was literally about just
introducing oh sighs which is cool but
it's like a theater they it's like
Osiris like he was in the game for like
a whole maybe at the entire expansion
like three minutes full time but if
everybody's done everything I'm just
gonna wrap it up on it oh nothing look
it's moving they're going hard all barri
right now you try to get them and get
them Pub none of this work
I'm an RPG guy definitely wickets move
back in the day out outside we game here
so I was definitely cooking them we got
football on back soon uh okay you went
to say some before you should probably
do disclosures on when um I don't know
if we're gonna be here next week coming
up this week with podcast you'll be fine
on your birthday oh oh hey lookie okay
cupcakes that you need anyway eighteen
no reason that I even brought that up is
because I was the cupcake make sure you
get the pink do you have say that they
were gonna give us all the old raids
back that was the whole thing before the
things like we will pull two glass back
we were going to get um Schroder back
Nessa you won your bet that's come on
your bet right yeah that's new one yes
correct yeah that's how you want your
bet all right so we're gonna get that
stuff back everybody's sitting here
fretting over all this rage stuff and
all this content let these guys destiny
actually does years before I can jump
I'm camping exactly all the stuff that
they're doing right and now looking at
someone's faults all the time because if
we look at people's faults all the time
we'll be talking about how to sleep all
the time and how they do with and being
cognizant of what's going on and we we
do appreciate when people put their good
foot forward so here on the trophy so
you can't get like the platinum this
weekend bungee saying that was according
to them that was a bug and they're gonna
patch that by Tuesday so that the people
will allowed to get the generator yeah
that was very reaches they put it behind
the paywall
and they fix these things so listen
let's give a shout out to these guys
it's these developers that are actually
listening because you have some
developers debt don't listen to you
battlefield battlefront 2 would even
matter if these companies do so let me
just quickly be the voice of other
people I want to know why you're in my
Mario wallet XP the XP throttling fiasco
many people expect more from this
expansion that was then what was coming
all of a sudden it had more weight on
its shoulders the expansion is what it
is it's move it's inching everything
towards what everybody wants it wasn't
gonna be there in one shot I just being
away from this expansion to resolve all
of this I'm not making excuses where
it's still in the state that it's in but
I know the way development works today
this thing might not get correct all the
way until spring it's up to the families
you can see okay whether or not they
gonna stick around so I understand Lord
at its point so we'll see you don't say
it's one of those things that this is
gonna take a time it's gonna be a
gradual process and it's up to the
fanbase if they're gonna stick around
and allow Bungie to do what it needs to
do to fix it so that's what I got now if
anybody's anything I would like to get
this poll off new people this week with
Paris games week PSX and the Game Awards
now over does Microsoft need to take a
more aggressive approach for their fan
base outside of III the choices are a
yes dedicated Microsoft Show is needed
for its fan base be know a strong III
Gamescom and Game Awards is more than
enough or see I don't care
six teraflops is greater than 4 Lord
Mari salute for coming through always
dealing with us Xbox guys shut out that
online arcade - man yeah man you can
find me on Twitter Jay underscore bar e
YT also you can follow us on the online
arcade on Twitter as well we just
launched a twitch channel so that's
where our streams is gonna be or a
tournament so that's gonna be twitch.tv
at the online arcade if you want to
follow us there go ahead we're trying to
get to like 100 followers oh you know we
can you know upgrade the channel a
little bit they won't look so basic you
guys are interested in any of the
tournaments you can sign up once again
at Tok that's how launched that sounds
that's a ll o n GE bout comedy baby I
get sick for two minutes right now for
2018 that we have a link be the message
on Twitter so I can put the hyperlink it
won't let them look the link in the chat
lake send it to me on Twitter on Twitter
yeah we don't promote that we got you so
yeah um yeah you know go over there I
just gonna be a lot of stuff coming for
the online arcade we're gonna definitely
try to fit everybody needs as far as
what type of games they like to play but
the interest is there most likely we're
gonna do a tornament there I heard you
got marvel over there man I mean
definitely come through to open lobby
that I'm always doing open lobbies on
much
that's what's up always a pleasure lower
Bari coming through with the PlayStation
nation
I mean Lord addict we can define people
find your shirt oh you can find me on
Twitter you can find me on youtube
follow me on PlayStation and Xbox I see
in because that's the one I'm gonna
start streaming blood-borne that will be
today probably a like for I'm mama
weapon I'm on going to be on what below
today so I'll probably do it to like
4:00 to 5:30 because I don't know it
just depends but yeah so uh I do want to
appreciate a you know Lord Jabari for
coming on it's always a fun to talk to a
PlayStation game or even though you know
yeah we're not supposed to number is
like six to one but it man Lord saw by
LP and on PSN and Xbox Live at being
sovereign and they're definitely big
shout out to de Bari coming into hostile
territory everything um all social media
also shout out to potentially perfect
I'll be debuted over there with that
show um but yeah it was a great show
barri
man love the new york love you come to
fearlessness oh yeah I love that man
listen I'm gonna support that get over
there with those two fighting games that
I do have in the link is to Jabbar ease
support support he's out here dude
giving good content and also that gamers
who play games podcast I love that name
playing games
yeah argue that we do that player games
[Laughter]
we spread that gaming realness on the
ILP make sure you I hit that like
subscribed all in a circle media outlets
also we got one more show for the year
that's gonna be next week unfortunate
nor Attica brother was not being able to
wish him a crazy happy birthday shout
out go get it for him
even though he's not gonna be there and
then oh yeah real quick after that also
the next year we're going to be back at
our 1 p.m. time so y'all get y'all sleep
on all that but uh again much love
appreciate the support everybody for
coming through we gonna wrap this thing
up no no yeah peace
you